what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 4 of the JavaScript basics
tutorials in the last tutorial we got
the blob moving now the only problem is
when it's going a little too slow but
too it just goes right off the canvas
and we need to start being able to
handle for that and just keep it in
bounds basically so to do that we're
going to use conditionals I'm also going
to speed it up again we were moving at
point two every update so now we're
gonna move at 1 so the next thing that
we want to do is let's see here so so
basically all we want to do is we want
to check for when the blob is beyond a
certain boundary we want to flip it
around so here we're making our
modification to X&Y but if like so so
let's just do X for now so the update
will be pretty subtle so actually let's
just do we'll do y plus equals is 0 for
now just so it moves along the x axis so
we can just see it so the question we
would ask is we want to ask so like with
it with a conditional there's a few
you've got if and Ella van Del's all
this stuff but or else if any way if and
then you throw in the condition so if
something is the case we do a thing so
the question would be in our for us it
would say if if X is greater than or
equal to we'll say canvas dot width and
so these are just comparison operators
there's a whole bunch of them there's
greater than or equal to there's also
double equal that just compares value
and then triple equal compares value and
data type so probably most of the time
you should be if you want to see does a
thing equal another thing use triple
equals I almost think double equal would
be very unique scenarios that you
probably don't want to run into so
too often anyway so we're gonna use if X
is greater than or equal to canvas width
if that's the case then we would say X
minus equals 1 so if that's the case we
do that otherwise else we'll say X plus
equals 1 let me just put this on its own
line as well so we'll leave Y and then
here this modification we don't really
need to make any more so we'll save that
and we'll run that and we see it goes
off and then it bounces oh we actually
wanted to go back the other way
so now it's just like wiggling right on
the edge so in this case really what
we'd want to say we need like some sort
of switch that's gonna flip back and
forth so instead what we might say is so
we've got x and y but then we also let's
add a let X change and we'll say that's
equal to 1 let Y change
we'll make that equal to 1 then we'll
come down here and rather than do this
we'll say X plus equals x change I'm
gonna leave Y at 0 for now and now it
will say we can kind of clear this up
and we really can just close it at this
point and then we would say X really if
it's greater than or equal to the canvas
with what we want to say is X change
equals negative 1 right and then you
could go back the other way and flip it
around both I'll talk about that in a
moment so really what we want to do is
actually just flip exchange so the way I
would do that is every 2 if you want to
flip something every single time you can
just do x equals negative 1 so if X
change is negative 1 well it's negative
1 times negative
one positive one if it's a positive 1
positive 1 times negative 1 is negative
1 so this will flip it back and forth
every single time so now if I save this
and we just leave this as exchange we
run that it should bounce back the other
way and then it goes back off the other
screen again so again we could throw in
another if statement all right so you
could say if that's case and then you
could have an L or else if hmm and then
have many more conditions the other
option because this would require else
if you could say X is less than or equal
to 0 because that's the other side you
could again do this and then X change X
change x equals negative 1 so in this
case let me just throw in my semicolons
in this case this should bounce back and
forth and it does but that's not really
probably the most ideal way to write
this and so we could be a little more
concise and save a couple lines and
instead what I would do is delete the
else if bits and in this conditional
everything that's inside of these
parentheses are the conditionals but
then you can also add in there's two
options you could have another check so
sometimes you want to have if something
is the case but then sometimes you want
to have a check where if something and
something else and maybe even something
else all right if something inside and
something is the case so if you wanted
to do and you would do a double
ampersand anyway you do double this and
then you could say X is less than or
equal to 0 of course that's totally
invalid but the but what we want it's
actually an or so to do an or it's this
bar it's that bar that's above your
Enter or return key this signifies or so
if X is greater than or equal
to the canvas width or if X is less than
or equal to zero we say X change and we
just want to flip the X change now we
want to do the same thing with the Y as
well so we'll say Y is greater than or
equal to the canvas height or Y is less
than or equal to zero then we want to
flip the why change now we just change
this to be Y change I don't actually
know the standard for JavaScript if if
you want to keep everything combined or
have spaces around this somebody knows
let me know I'm probably going to try to
just put spaces around them to be honest
okay so let's go ahead save and we'll
run that and now it should just bounce
back and forth every time and it does it
looks okay now the bouncing is kind of
boring so you have a couple of options
here what you could what you could do to
make the bouncing a little more exciting
the easiest change that we could make
honestly would just be uh make this not
a uniformly sized canvas so rather than
a height of 100
rather than high to 200 pixels let's
make it 133 pixels
let me run that and then now the
bouncing will be a little more random
just because it's not gonna do a perfect
pattern every time so okay now that's
pretty cool but now that we've conquered
that the next thing that we want to do
is we want to have many blobs right and
then we want to probably have those
blobs interact with each other in some
way
so what do we do right and if we look at
this blob function already it's probably
getting a little out of hand but also
the usage of X change in Y change in
here it's gonna be really challenging
for us to have many blobs so then we're
gonna have to start you know finagling
these things and moving them around
and this is kind of the point where we
kind of fork out into the many different
paradigms of programming for different
languages and especially with JavaScript
this is a language that's a
multi-paradigm programming language so
you've got things like functional
programming as well as like
object-oriented programming and then
you've got people that are just straight
scripting and you've got things
in-between people mixing and matching so
it gets kind of messy and it's really
challenging like one of the things I've
just taken for granted and Python is
like I could pretty much figure anything
out in Python like instantly I can look
at source code and be like ok I see cuz
I know exactly what they're doing
whereas in JavaScript
even though even things like let in
Const these are not new they've been
around for a long time but most of the
examples that you're gonna like find
when you like look online or still using
like var and class is not a super new
keyword like to do object are in your
program like for the longest time people
have been doing object-oriented
programming basically with functions but
now there's classes which we're gonna
cover in the next video but you might
find that you run into somebody using
the function method of creating classes
which have methods that's why I've made
that face anyways can be super confusing
and so anyways just take take take note
and when you search for stuff search for
like something something something and
then like do es6 or something like that
and hopefully you'll be able to find a
more current version I thought Python
was bad with the 2.7 and 3 split but I
think JavaScript is even worse because
both for like both ways work and the old
style just sticks around because that's
what's most documented so anyway
fascinating so that's it for now if
you've got questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
if you want to support the channel you
know what to do you click that beautiful
blue join button below the video and
support me otherwise I will see you guys
in another video